so again we have these three topics that
we will cover in the microbiome obesity
Precision Nutrition for the gut
microbiome skin aging and Beauty for the
skin microbiome and then pregnancy and
femtech for vaginal microbiome now
there's a lot of overlap you will find
for example that in the femtech world
women are treating different uh you know
micro microbiome related conditions with
pre and probiotics that are taken orally
so their gut microbiome based and you
also find that some gut microbiome
changes can affect things like balding
and and dandruff and and that's also
um you know skin related but also gut
related so really this microbiome
related space there's a lot of overlap
between these different areas but in
each one of these areas there are also
specific things to consider as we think
about you know what is knee needed who
is it needed for and what is innovative
and different about it
obesity and Precision Nutrition is I
think the most um kind of widely known
uh topic where we have
um one primary Challenge and again you
will hear from experts on this as well
but I just want to give you kind of a
preview of what that will cover so one
important consideration here is that
anyone can diet right I mean if you stop
eating and I stop eating we're going to
lose a lot of weight right away the
problem isn't that the problem is
sustaining that weight loss over time
and addressing specific challenges to
different individuals at different age
ages and and conditions of their body
that will really help them to lose
weight in the long term and feel good
about it at the same time so so that
will be something that we will talk
about in that session as I mentioned
skin aging and beauty
is a huge industry
um traditionally of course more women
are focused on that but today even men
are aware of their looks and and kind of
how their skin
um and comfort of their skin is uh
related and that's why you see and you
know silver lined clothing and and
that's why you're seeing all kinds of uh
you know questions about whether this
kind of lotion or that kind of lotion is
appropriate for what type of skin so I
think a really interesting topic uh with
existing products on the market already
that are claiming you know that this
works and and how it works exactly so I
think a very interesting topic there as
well
finally pregnancy and authentic you know
uh all of us uh men women we all um have
a link to
um you know pregnancy and to um uh you
know childbirth
um so I think fertility
um you know is a big uh business uh but
also there's a lot of um other kind of
things that we might not necessarily you
know uh hear about or understand I think
that we recently spoke to an expert who
is actually working on a company in that
field and she was telling us about how
you know women a lot of times don't know
um how the microbiome factors in to
these decisions that they have to make
and you know a lot of clinicians don't
know and really Health Care is starting
to become a lot more focused on
prevention
um rather than treatment and I think
this is a huge opportunity because the
microbiome just by its property is
something that can establish a certain
condition in its environment and I think
that
um you know this is a very um specific
kind of a challenge where those kinds of
preventive and long-term benefits are
extremely important for the outcomes
all right so let's briefly uh kind of
talk about the major focus of today and
the major focus of today is what are the
specific skills that you have to know or
what are these data science computer
science and engineering type uh
solutions that we think are most
promising in this field
so as you know one of the major
um kind of ways that we can study the
microbiome is through sequencing and the
reason for that is because culturing
bacteria right we could culture bacteria
but unfortunately only like one percent
of all bacteria could be cultured in the
lab and when it is cultured in the lab
it is now in isolation and because it's
in isolation we don't understand how
those microbes actually interact with
the other microbes in the microbiome
because microbiome is like a community
that works together and so sequencing
allows us to actually understand what
kinds of bacteria we have and
potentially what kinds of
um you know enzymatic or active
compounds they produce and and that's a
very important kind of a technology that
really for the first time ever allows us
to see what is happening in the real
time so so uh you know what's important
to understand well what's important to
understand for some of these techniques
is that they work in different ways
um they they have different methods of
sample preparation and we'll talk about
that as well because really how do you
sample skin microbiome you know
um you know for example we can have an
oily skin and you know then you can have
a swipe and understand what's in the
swipe but what if you have dandruff I
mean how do you understand uh the micro
microbial community
of a dry skin right so so there are ways
to do this this there are techniques to
do this we'll talk about that um during
the hackathon preparation as well and
you know when you sequence
um now the challenge becomes well you
know a lot of this data that is uh
prepared in a certain way after it is
sequenced it has very specific
properties and the property really is
that you have
um different approaches to process that
data preparing it for analysis and the
preparation of the data for analysis is
critical for your analysis to be
accurate and for it to be clear and
beyond that as I mentioned we have
different methods of data generation
that perhaps result in a challenge of
monotonomics integration because we're
talking about you know the microbiome
and maybe the metabolo or maybe even the
host gene expression right so there's a
lot to think about as we approach this
kind of data now there are some standard
tools in the field and it's important to
understand what these tools are I mean a
very kind of popular package of tools
called chyme or chime is a collection of
tools designed for 16s ribosome RNA uh
and and you know there are other things
that we should think about because
really just beyond these standard tools
that we have to understand because they
address very specific uh noise issues
and very specific reproducibility and
accuracy issues we also need to think
about well what other methods are out
there for example there are 16s
ribosomal RNA hyper variable region
amplicon there's also just the full 16s
ribosome RNA amplicon there's full
metagenomics where we try to assemble
individual genomes that has met a
transcriptome
transcriptomics where we try to
understand what are the genes that are
being produced by AI these bacteria by
these
organisms there's metabolomics which
looks at active compounds they're not
proteins but they're metabolites so
smaller kind of active compounds that
are being generated and produced and
there are methods to do that like
um you know lcms and msms there's gene
expression studies again how dust our
body the host respond to the changes in
the microbiome for example if we talk
about inflammation a major Topic in the
leaky gut or uh you know maybe even skin
rashes right how do we connect the
changes in the microbiome or the
expression changes not the composition
changes but expression changes to how
our body reacts and even genomics you
know what kind of genomic or genetic
properties kind of tend to fall in a
specific type of a microbiome in
addition to that there are three
additional things that I think are very
important from a computer science kind
of perspective one of of them is machine
learning so why machine learning well
the reason why machine learning is such
a big deal is because these data sets as
they grow and when they grow that means
we have better representation of
different individual types we also need
more complex and kind of sensitive
methods to find and extract patterns
an important part here is also
visualization right and visualization I
think is not just having a plot today
visualization is much more connected to
the data because it is interactive and
it allows us to quickly search and find
patterns that we know how to interpret
so a lot of it is about connecting
different sources of data together and
then finally cloud computing so why
cloud computing well one of the main
reasons cloud computing is such a big
deal in this case is because once you
produce something you would like it to
be usable by many different individuals
on demand without having to put upfront
investments into Hardware that is
necessary for these kinds of
applications to operate so environments
on the cloud a lot of which are provided
free of cost initially are going to be
very useful for prototyping and
designing something that works today on
a small population and then events
actually can be used by larger and
larger users without that upfront
investment but of course the cloud
technology is nothing more than Simply
Having that accessible Hardware
elsewhere and so understanding the
process of accessing different compute
resources different database type
resources and even different kinds of
you know storage data storage resources
are going to be very important to be
able to produce something that is
actually valuable
a good example of that is an
understanding of how recommendation
systems are working today and what kind
of innovation could be added to them
when we think about the information that
the microbiome can provide for things
like activity tracking Precision
Nutrition and things like that and a
good example here is this this is an
example from a another hackathon that a
team of students actually made where
they made a food recommendation system
that relies on machine learning that
asks questions about your preferences
your diet choices and things like that
and recommends similar Foods through
this recommendation system so what you
will see is that a lot of the approaches
are to find a similar comparable or
alternative right so for example let's
think about
users that let's say have different
kinds of microbial communities in their
gut well and I D in an ideal world for a
machine learning recommendation system
what you can say is once I identify a
group of similar individuals I can say
well this is what I know about this
group and this person is new how could I
recommend to them something that works
for the rest but if you think about the
microbiome that becomes kind of
challenging because even describing what
groups are identifying how to match
those groups and then understanding what
do those groups actually mean are all
areas where Innovation is critically
needed
so here's a a brief example of you know
how this recommendation system actually
works uh you can see that you know you
kind of type in so again you can start
thinking about uh you know how this idea
could be further developed into
something that incorporates the
microbiome
um and kind of helps us think about a
user using something like this
um again you know maybe once or maybe
continuously you know using it to
actually get some ideas about you know
what they
um what they might find useful so again
I am not necessarily the expert in all
of these things uh but I do want to
share
um how um you know a lot of these
um
things
um are you know ideas that I think
everyone will learn from by listening to
experts in the field and I am pleased to
know that there's a whole panel of
experts that are going to be presenting
um from you know technology backgrounds
like sequencing from industry uh
Innovation perspective like even
investors that have invested in this
field and can tell you what has worked
what hasn't worked and why
um experts in computer science and
machine learning that have built such
recommendation systems and also
researchers that continue to identify
insights that maybe are sitting on the
shelf and did not find an opportunity to
be translated into a real product so a
lot of interesting experts that we you
can learn from during this hackathon
now primarily this hackathon is for our
partner program so as you probably know
uh Pine biotech is working with academic
Partners around the world in Africa in
the US in India and we develop these
relationships with universities because
universities are kind of The Gatekeepers
for students to be introduced to these
kinds of topics and so we would like
them to have a clear understanding of
how
um you know these these ideas that they
learn about could also be translated
further and so this specific opportunity
is for the partner University program
but we are also looking for additional
Partners so if you are here today and
you are a faculty and you teach students
in some way we would love to talk to you
after this webinar to identify a way for
us to work together
you know I think we can bring a lot of
value to this kind of
bioinformatics training with outcomes
with practical outcomes like this
hackathon and we're also looking for
your ideas and your contribution to help
shape programs like these as we continue
to grow this partnership program
now as already mentioned you know this
is not something that we just recently
started I mean we have been doing this
for several years and we have over 24
000 participants on our portal across
162 countries many different
universities that we have worked with
and and I hope that you know through
this hackathon and through this
partnership program we would be able to
connect as well and and continue to grow
this um uh this industry together
so if anyone would like to speak about
that I welcome you to reach out to me uh
personally especially if you are in the
US but also uh the Director of Business
Development uh Mohit mazundar you can
email us on these email addresses that's
probably the best way but also we
welcome you know you to connect with us
on LinkedIn uh of course you know find
us on social media and would love to
talk to you more about all of this